REST OF HIS LIFE IN PRISON.
>> Sean: THANK YOU, TREY
SPARED THE BITE AND ECONOMY IS
CONTINUING TO FAIL ON EVERY
FRONT TONIGHT.
INFLATION, SURGING, FORTY-YEAR
HYATT, GAS PRICES NOW AT A
RECORD HIGH ONCE AGAIN FEAR THE
STOCK MARKET CONTINUES TO
TUMBLE.
HAMMERING AMERICANS RETIREMENT
ACCOUNTS.
ALTHOUGH THE BITE AND
WHITE HOUSE CONTINUES TO BLAME
EVERYONE BUT THEMSELVES.
AND ACCORDING TO GALLUP,
AMERICANS ARE NOW TAKING WALT
DOE MIKE NOTICE WITH 52% OF
VOTERS SAY THEY WERE WORRIED
ABOUT MAINTAINING THEIR VERY
STANDARD OF LIVING, SO WHILE THE
LEFT MAY TRY TO DISTRACT FROM
ALL OF THESE FAILURES AND TRY TO
FUEL MORE HYSTERIA AGAINST THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT, BIDEN'S
SELF-INFLICTED CRISES IS STARING
AMERICANS RIGHT IN THE FACE AND
PRETTY MUCH EVERY SERVICE, EVERY
GOOD YOU BUY AT EVERY STORE YOU
GO TO.
HERE WITH DIRECTION,
SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM IS WITH US.
SENATOR, WELCOME BACK.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE THING I CAN
POINT TO THAT THE DEMOCRATS CAN
RUN ON AND SAY, WE HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL HERE, THEY ARE, OR
ANYWHERE.
THEY SEEM TO HAVE NOW LOCKED
INTO AN EXTREME POSITION ON
ABORTION AND EVEN SUPPORTING
DOCS IN THESE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES.
WEDNESDAY OF THIS WEEK, WE ARE
EXPECTING A CHUCK SCHUMER VOTE
TO CODIFY ROE.
DO WE KNOW THE LANGUAGE IN THAT
BILL?
HOW EXTREME IS IT?
>> IT DOESN'T CODIFY ROE, WHAT
IT WOULD DO WOULD ALLOW ABORTION
TO BE HAD RIGHT UP UNTIL THE
MOMENT OF BIRTH.
ROE V. WADE SAYS THE STATE CAN
REGULATE ABORTION AFTER
VIABILITY OF THE FETUS IS ABOUT
23-24 WEEKS.
THIS GO WELLS BEYOND, SO THE
ANSWER TO ROE V. WADE BEING
POTENTIALLY REPEALED IS TO
NATIONALIZE A LAW THAT ALLOWS
ABORTION RIGHT UP TO THE MOMENT
OF BIRTH.
THAT IS PRETTY EXTREME.
THIS WILL BE A REFERENDUM OF
JOE BIDEN'S ECONOMIC AND
NATIONAL SECURITY POLICY.
IT WON'T BE A REFERENDUM ON ROW
VIEW WADE.
THE ELECTION WILL BE DECIDED
ABOUT, YOU CAN'T BUY BABY
FORMULA -- I BET 100% OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE IF YOU HAVE A
BABY HAD TO BRING THE BABY AND
OF THE WORLD IT SHOULD BE ABLE
TO BUY FORMULA.
THERE'S A CRISIS WHEN IT COMES
TO BABY FORMULA.
THEY CAN FILL UP YOUR GAS TANK.
I SPENT $65 FILLING UP MY GAS
TANK TODAY AND IT WAS THREE
QUARTERS -- THAT WAS JUST THREE
QUARTERS.
THE BORDER IS BROKEN.
THREE THINGS SHOULD HAPPEN HERE.
JOE BIDEN SHOULD LOOK AT THE
CAMERA IN THE EYE UNTIL EVERY
PROTESTER, LEAVE THE JUDGES HOME
ALONE.
YOU ARE COMMITTING A CRIME.
IT IS ILLEGAL TO GO AND TRY TO
INTIMIDATE A JUDGE WHO IS
HEARING A CASE AT THEIR HOME
LIKE IT WOULD BE A JUROR.
JOE BIDEN NEEDS TO SAY THAT.
WE ALL ASKED TRUMP TO TELL THE
PROTESTERS TO LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
PRESIDENT BIDEN, HERE'S WHAT I
WANT YOU TO DO.
GET ON TELEVISION UNTIL THESE
PEOPLE TO LEAVE THE JUDGES ALONE
BECAUSE THEY ARE COMMITTING A
CRIME.
>> Sean: SENATOR, THE PROBLEM
WITH YOUR ADVICE IS THAT SHIP
HAS SAILED.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS ALREADY
SAID -- IN FRONT OF THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES HOMES.
THEY HAVE ALREADY GIVEN THE TASK
OF APPROVAL.
>> NUMBER TWO, I'M GOING TO
WRITE A LETTER TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND ASK HIM,
WHAT IS HIS INTERPRETATION.
THERE IS A LAW IN THE BOOKS THAT
PREVENTS JUDGES FROM BEING
ARRESTED AND PICKETED WHILE THEY
ARE DECIDED A CASE.
SAME FOR A JUROR.
THEY ARE LITERALLY VIOLATING THE
LAW.
THEY VIOLATED THE LAW WHEN THEY
WENT INTO THE CAPITAL,
TRESPASSING AND THE CAPITAL,
TAKING MATTERS INTO THEIR OWN
HANDS.
EVERYBODY YELLED AT TRUMP, TELL
HIM TO LEAVE.
HERE'S WHAT I'M TELLING
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
TELL THESE PEOPLE TO LEAVE THE
JUDGES ALONE, DON'T GO TO THEIR
HOME, THIS IS ILLEGAL, IT'S
WRONG, IT'S BAD FOR AMERICA.
JOE BIDEN NEEDS TO STEP UP AND
TAKE MATTERS INTO HIS OWN HANDS.
AS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, SPEAK FORCEFULLY
TO THESE PEOPLE AND TRY TO GET
AN OUTCOME IN A CASE THAT
VIOLATES OUR LAW.
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND, YOU
NEED TO ISSUE AN OPINION
TOMORROW SAYING THAT THE
ACTIVITY IN FRONT OF THE JUDGES
HOUSE VIOLATES THE LAW.
>> Sean: I WOULD LIKE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO WEIGH IN, I
WOULD LIKE THE DIRECTOR TO WEIGH
IN, I WOULD LIKE THE
SECRETARY -- THE DOMESTIC
TERRORISM WAS THE BIGGEST ACT OF
SOCIETY.
DON'T YOU THINK IT'S A LITTLE
BIT DANGEROUS ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
SHOW UP IN FRONT OF THE HOMES OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES WHEN THEY
ARE FACING AN IMPORTANT
DECISION?
ISN'T THAT INTIMIDATION,
HARASSMENT, AND THE TYPE OF
THING THAT THE COURT SHOWS IS
ILLEGAL.
>> IT IS ILLEGAL TO GO TO THE
CAPITAL.
WE ALL AGREE.
YOU AND I, EVERYBODY ELSE WITH
HALF A BRAIN SAID LEAVE THE
CAPITAL, THIS IS NOT THE WAY TO
DEAL WITH AN ELECTION.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET PEOPLE TO
STAND OUT BEFORE SOMEBODY GETS
HURT.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS THE
VIOLATION OF THE LAW.
YOU NEED TO SPEAK UP.
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND, YOU
NEED TO ISSUE AN OPINION TELLING
PEOPLE THEY ARE IN VIOLATION
LOSS.
IF YOU DON'T DO THAT, YOU ARE
GIVING COVERED ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD'VE BEEN THEY WANT TO DO
IT AND HE PASSED ON IT MULTIPLE
TIMES.
I WOULD ARGUE IF ANYTHING DOES
HAPPEN, HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT.
IT IS AMAZING, THEY DIDN'T CARE
ABOUT THE RIOTS OF 2020.
THEY ONLY CARED ABOUT THE ONE
RIOT.
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO CALL THEM UP DIDN'T
CALL THEM UP THAT DAY.
>> HE SAID LEAVE, HE TOLD HIM TO
LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
BIDEN, TELL THEM TO LEAVE THE
JUDGES AT HOME ALONE.
HE TOLD HIM TO LEAVE, YOU NEED
TO TELL HIM